we're told that Elena wants to build a
one-sample Z interval to estimate what
proportion of computers produced at a
factory have a certain defect she
chooses a confidence level of 94 percent
a random sample of 200 computers show
that 12 computers have the defect what
critical value Z star should Elena use
to construct this confidence interval so
before I even ask you to pause this
video let me just give you a little
reminder of what a critical value is
remember the whole point behind
confidence intervals are we have some
true population parameter in this case
it is the proportion of computers that
have a defect so there's some true
population proportion we don't know what
that is
but we try to estimate it we take a
sample in this case it's the sample a
random sample of 200 computers we take a
random sample and then we estimate this
by calculating the sample proportion but
then we also want to construct a
confidence interval and remember a
confidence interval it would not what at
a 94 percent confidence level means that
if we were to keep doing this and if we
were to keep creating intervals around
these statistics so maybe that's the
confidence interval around that one
maybe if we were to do it again that's
the confidence interval around that one
that 94 percent that roughly as I keep
doing this over and over again that 90
that roughly 94 percent of these
intervals are going to overlap with our
true population parameter
and the way that we do this is we take
the statistic let me just write this in
general form even if we're not talking
about a proportion it could be if we're
trying to estimate the the population
mean so we take our statistic statistic
and then we go plus or minus around that
statistic plus or minus around that
statistic and then we say okay how many
standard deviations for the sampling
distribution do we want to go above or
beyond so the number of standard
deviations we want to go that is our
critical value and then we multiply that
times the standard deviation of the
statistic of the statistic now in this
particular
situation our statistic is P hat from
this one sample that Elena made so said
one sample proportion that she was able
to calculate plus or minus Z star and
we're gonna think about which is Z star
cuz that's essentially the question the
critical value so plus or minus some
critical value x and what we do because
in order to actually calculate the true
standard deviation of the sampling
distribution of the sample proportions
well then you actually have to know the
population parameter but we don't know
that
so we multiply that times the standard
error of the statistic and we we've done
this in previous videos but the key
question here is what is our Z star and
what we really needed to think about is
assuming that the sampling distribution
is roughly normal and this is the mean
of it which would actually be a true
population parameter which we do not
know but how many standard deviations
above and below the mean in order to
capture 94 percent of the probability 94
percent of the area so this distance
right over here where this is 94 percent
this number of standard deviations that
is Z star right over here now all we
have to really do is look it up on a Z
table but even there we have to be
careful and you should always be careful
which type of Z table you're using or if
using a calculator function what your
calculator function does because a lot
of Z tables will actually do something
like this for given Z they'll say what
is the total area going all the way Nate
from negative infinity up to including Z
standard deviations above above the mean
so when you look up a lot of Z tables
they will give you they will give you
this area so one way to think about this
we want to find the critical value we
want to find the Z that leaves not 6%
unshaded in but leaves 3% unshaded in
where did I get that from well a hundred
percent minus 94 percent is 6% but
remember this is going to be symmetric
on the left on the right so you're going
to want three percent not shaded in over
here and three percent not shade
didn't over here so when I look at a
traditional Z table that is viewing it
from this point of view this cumulative
area what I really want to do is find
the Z that is leaving 3% open over here
which would mean the Z that is filling
in 97 percent over here not 94 percent
but if I find this Z but if I were to
stop it right over there as well then I
would have three percent available there
and then the true area that we're
filling in would be 94 percent so with
that out of the way let's look that up
what Z gives us fills us fills in 97
percent of the area so I got AZ table
this is actually the one that you would
see if you were say taking AP statistics
and we would just look up where do we
get to 97 percent and so it is 97
percent looks like it is right about
here that looks like the closest number
this is 6 10 thousandths above it this
is only one ten-thousandth below it and
so this is let's see you would look at
the row first if we look at the row it
is 1.8 1.8 8 is our Z so going back to
this right over here if our Z is equal
to one point eight eight so this is
equal to one point eight eight then all
of this area up to an including one
point eight eight standard deviations
above the mean that would be 97 percent
but if you were to go one point eight
eight standard deviations above the mean
and one point eight eight standard
deviations below the mean
that would leave three percent open on
either side and so this would be 94
percent so this would be 94 percent but
to answer their question what critical
z-value or what critical values Z star
well this is going to be one point eight
eight and we're done